bonheur national brut le bnb un concept
unique au monde qui régit toute la
politique au bhoutan
celui qui le calcul travail dans ce
vaste chalet qui respire la quiétude
car maura et philosophe il a été chargé
de fabriquer la recette du bonheur
[Musique]
car maura a sélectionné 72 ingrédients
qui l'a testé auprès des habitants par
exemple l'utilisation du temps la
connaissance de la nature la confiance
dans les institutions
le niveau de vie et le bien-être
psychologique
il distingue les émotions positives
comme la compassion la sérénité la
générosité des émotions négatives
faste et c'est la frustration l'égoïsme
et la jalousie nous les mesureront quel
est le pourcentage de gens qui
ressentent fréquemment des émotions
négatives et les
par exemple vous pouvez voir la
distribution des émotions négatives
district par district et c'est dans la
capitale que le niveau est le plus élevé
car maura va transformer toutes ces
données en un chiffre après d'obscurs
opération
'l'indice du bnb est égal à 0 64 mon
score parait-il le gouvernement va
chercher à l'augmenter
si on le compare à bien d'autres pays
malgré le fait que nos revenus
financiers soient bas le peuple
bhoutanais est un peuple très heureux
la raison c'est que les revenus
financiers ne sont pas la clé du
bien-être
pour les autorités bhoutanaise le bnb
est même plus important que le pnb
pratique quand on est un pays peu
développés malin aussi car l'idée est
une belle vitrine pour les occidentaux
fabien compliqué
nous soumettons la recette à nos
français
d'abord scepticisme
mais très vite il se projette
surtout philippe et geneviève qui ne
sont pas retraités mais cadre
mois titre personnel
que j'ai beaucoup consacré au travail
que ce soit personnel je pense
même s'il ya des gens qui sont aux 35
heures je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui n'y sont pas il voire pas du
tout il ya très peu de personnes qui ont
une vie personnelle intense profonde qui
prennent le temps de bien de faire un
peu ce que moi j'appelle de
l'introspection c'est à dire que se
situer par rapport aux autres on est
dans une situation qu'on sort mais on
veut avoir plus que le voisin on est
très individualiste donc on a oublié
certaines valeurs fondamentales à mon
sens
cette politique du bonheur qui fait
s'interroger les occidentaux qui l'a
décidé la famille royale elle-même
nous allons approcher cette fois sans
nos touristes à l'occasion d'une
cérémonie féerique
le bhoutan couronne son cinquième roi
à deux pas du tapis rouge robert fait
partie des invités
le photographe est célèbre au bhoutan
il nous tient la chronique mondaine
local
rachid slimani
c'était la seconde est plus que
quatrième roi du bhoutan
voilà donc le roi
jigme est haut en dessous qu à 28 ans
c'est le roi le plus jeune du monde
comme sa démocratie les bhoutanais ont
voté pour la première fois l'an dernier
il tient à saluer tous ses invités
et lorsqu'il reconnaît robert il
s'approche
il faut que je vous dise bonjour
de mon talent et vous
le jeune roi et le photographe se
connaissent depuis 15 ans
oui
il est comme ça c'est un pont du réel je
pense que là une espèce de bonté
naturelle en été et qu'il ait manifesté
qui se sent bon pied bon donc c'est un
homme charmant
est ce tellement important pour vous de
saluer tout le monde
c'est très important
notre peuple est important chaque
individu compte c'est ça le bonheur
national brut
l'individu compte
je suis très heureux que vous soyez ici
merci beaucoup